hey everyone this is Steve launch up
with collider I am thrilled to be back
at our studio at the cinema center at
marble uh which David I'm sure is upset
that I've butchered the name five times
but I'm joking around uh listen I really
want to say a strong congratulations to
you guys for kill uh thank you thank you
so much I thought you guys did such a
great job with this I had a blast
watching but I'm also sick and twisted
so I'm just gonna say but um so everyone
watching won't have seen the movie yet
and I hate asking this but how have you
been describing the film to like friends
and family don't watch watch it if you
have balls I don't know I'll speak in
Hindi is it okay if I speak in Hindi
listen for just for the tag Lane sure
100.
if you have guts come to the Halls
the thing about this though is I've seen
a decent amount of Indian Cinema not not
a ton but I have seen Indian Cinema and
I've never seen a film like this out of
India so I am curious was it tough for
you to make to get this made because
it's really bloody it's very violent and
it's not something that typically comes
out of India uh so to tell you the truth
uh actually it was not that difficult to
make it because when I uh met gunit and
Karan they jumped at the opportunity of
making such a film and I'm really really
thankful to them because this kind of a
genre is not made in India at all this
is the first extreme action film coming
out of India and uh you know so uh when
I went and told them about the story
um
they just wanted to make it they said
it's high time it's high time we've not
tried this
and uh that's how that's how quickly it
got processed I'm curious for the two of
you though this is again let's stress
the word violent this is pretty violent
and I'm curious for both of you what
were there any people in your life
managers agents I'm not exactly sure how
it is
um on that you know uh uh uh telling you
this is too violent you should not do
this or were they encouraging you saying
this is gonna be really cool they were
like I I like it do this they had that
sadistic pleasure from that so they said
go for it and just do it
yeah I mean as a child while growing up
I've only watched action movies you know
all kind of action films and I wanted
wanted to be a part of such a project
and when it came my way I was all up for
it I was like there's no chance I'm
letting this go no matter what people
gonna say and I think it came to me uh
through my producer only like the guy I
was doing a film with Dharma production
I was doing a film with them already so
it came through them so I trusted him
and he's also my mentor so of course it
uh the opportunity that I got and the
narration that I got from him was so
good it was amazing it was something
that while narrating the entire film
came to life and I could only imagine
myself doing it and that's the only
question I asked him that when are we
starting this when I when are we like
can we like and then my second question
was that am I a part of this am I
already selected please tell me I am and
he was like We'll see to that
I'm so curious in terms of this movie
has a ton of action and I'm I'm curious
how long did you actually have to film
the movie like how many days so in all
of the shot for 77 days
uh out of which around uh 66 days was we
shooting the train sequence
and action part we shot around 58 days
or 57 days
no yeah right I I'm still buying the
oriosis in the workshops of action so we
did a lot of rehearsals sure we almost
prepped for around nine months there it
is I wanted to that's what I'm looking
for like how long yeah yeah we prepped
for nine months so for almost three
months these guys were training and uh
so we got an action director from uh
Korea Mr oyang
and he's he's uh he's been a part of
snow piercer so he came on board and he
got his team and there was a uh we had
another action director from India Mr
parvez Khan so uh both of them they
trained these guys for three months and
not just these guys the other
uh goons were who are who are playing in
the film so there are some 45 goons so
they trained them as well because we had
to cast them we couldn't use the
stuntmans to do that because they had to
emote in the film
so we we cast them and then we trained
with them these guys trained with them
for almost three months uh this used to
happen I have so many follow-ups so many
questions so uh one of the things that
the beginning of the film is very
colorful and bright and it's not what I
expected and then it it talk a little
bit about how you set up this world and
how maybe it's a little different than
people might expect so uh
um our Director of Photography uh Mr
Rafi Mahmoud uh he he came up with the
idea that because you know
um the film starts becoming Grimmer and
Grimmer and Grimmer so when we open up
we should not even give a hint to the
audience what it is gonna come after
after 10 minutes what are you gonna see
so
um so that's the reason why it starts
off with almost like it probably is
going to be a love story and we wanted
to trick the audience over there to be
very honest till the time we introduce
raghav in the film and suddenly you see
this guy who's at the working at the gas
gas station and he turns and from there
onwards uh the the lighting as well as
the colors start changing
to a point in the middle of the film
after which
when the hits the roof
it just starts going demorandom or
random or and darker and darker and also
so uh we we took a we took um creative
Liberty because that's not how the
trains are lit in India
uh so slowly we started changing the
colors and you don't even notice that
how how gradually the colors are have
started changing unless you're a big
film fan yes yes you know yeah just
throwing that out there for for both of
you
um this this had to have been a very
daunting and challenging shoot because
of the physicality and how much you had
to do in a in a very limited space so
talk a little bit about the challenges
as an actor to deliver a performance
while doing action and you you know you
are in a very tight quarters for the
whole time pretty much the whole time
the whole time for me I think I have
long limbs so it I was really sometimes
you know we used to take a two two three
three shots just because I used to hit
my hand in some of the bogey and then I
had to active like so but yeah it was
challenging but it was really fun and
you know the whole all the during our
shoot all the time we were like only
like this
because Indian trains move a lot you
know you've been there yeah so whenever
I used to go home back home and sleep
I'm all almost like this
so 77 days nine months I was like this
whole time and it was the train
all the time and he was so much into
that space and you know that in that
character and that body language I had
to like I I worked on that during the
prep
so it yeah it was challenging but it was
really fun loving man and it was it's a
reactor's dream to perform to play that
character we could do this all over
again yeah all right on the cruise yeah
that was that was my quote which
everybody's stealing now I would do it
all over again so yeah considering the
fact that it was uh physically
exhausting not only that but for me it
was mentally more exhausting to be very
honest with you because uh of course we
shot it for uh like 77 days
consecutively
but the the film happens in a span of
two hours so right so the maintaining
the emotional continuity of the
character was everything for me because
he's always there something or the other
is always happening with him like he
gets into a fight then he's taking some
time to like you just to catch a breath
and then his uh something or the other
keeps happening to him like you know
he's always trying to catch a breath and
then when that thing happens the the big
twitch that happens in the film the
pre-interville sequence that happens
maintaining what happened to him the
person loss throughout the film was the
biggest challenge for me because that
has to be evident on his face throughout
till the very end so I think they were
nice lives I spoke to sir also like they
were I was getting dreams like you know
I was in my dreams I'm thinking of the
sequence that I had shot a day prior the
action sequence was running in my mind
throughout and I'm getting up I slept
for six seven hours but I'm feeling that
probably I didn't sleep at all because
my mind was constantly thinking about
the singing I was in that Loop so it was
mentally uh more exhausting for me then
physically because physically it was not
so much I think I thoroughly enjoyed it
well the other thing is that I'm sure
for both of you you're also thinking
about what are my moves tomorrow what do
I need to remember what are we doing
tomorrow and like you know like it's a
marathon from I've never acted but every
actor tells me it's like it's a marathon
especially an action film I used to look
forward to it to be honest it's not like
that I was thinking I was thinking about
what's going to happen tomorrow but it
was more in a very positive light that
okay tomorrow is the same thing that I'm
gonna do the same set is the same set of
people I'm gonna see is the same
sequence I was looking forward to it
more than being nervous about it so that
was my take on things while shooting
generally what happens when you are well
prepped for me I'm talking about me my
personal experience when you're well
prepped I tend to just forget before I
go to the set if I'm well prepped I
forget what I learned so that way while
doing in the moment the surprise and the
element of surprise is there for me and
I get discoveries and I can discover new
things on the set in the train during my
scenes or in the not in the fight fight
we choreographed but during the scenes I
tried I try to forget everything and
just be there and I've subconsciously
whatever I've learned as a character or
whatever it is I just go there and have
I discover new new things and that's
what I uh love about this job of mine so
that's why I I prepped a lot nine months
and then I took a week I think two weeks
to just forget it and do different
things and see if my body is still
working like that and I used to come on
this on set and just discover and
explore sure yeah but there's also a lot
of muscle memory because you've you've
pressed for so long subconsciously it's
Karate Kid I've seen Cobra Kai
and then one of the things that I
enjoyed uh about your character and the
performance is that sometimes in America
in American Cinema the lead actor
um like can't get hurt I don't want to
say anything about Jason Statham who I'm
a huge fan of but he can't lose a fight
you know and what I appreciated is that
you got the kicked out of you in
this movie so talk a little bit about
what it's like playing someone who is
you know getting their ass kicked in and
you are caked in blood you got Cuts you
know you know what I mean I mean for
that I think all the credit goes to the
director for writing such a scene and
making him more human
I feel I totally relate because earlier
if you would have seen there was one
sequence where like of course as you
rightly mentioned that he's somebody
he's a human after all he's a Commando
he's not he's God or he's some uh uh
some some some Superman or some Batman
who can't be defeated so I think the the
more human he is the more relatable he
can be with you know Common People
because no matter how strong you are
there will be somebody who's gonna be
stronger than you oh and that person's
in the movie and that person is in the
movie so I think uh that was some
brilliant writing and some brilliant
thought that the director brought in in
the script and I mean that's that's all
him that's all him I have a question so
every time I speak to filmmakers
directors I always talk about editing
because it's the most important thing
it's where it all comes together so talk
a little bit about what you learned from
friends and family screenings that ended
up impacting the finished film
um so my editor shiv his name is shiv uh
he's a brilliant editor he's a you know
it's it's actually
um
so
what so the process is that when so I've
finished the shoot I will not enter the
edit room till the time the first edit
is done sure because uh I feel editor is
a filmmaker on his own
so I want him to have his take have a go
on the film from his side
and see what he can bring in
and to be honest there was a huge change
which he brought in
uh so
earlier we were entering the film
entering the train pretty late
he just threw things out
and uh we ended the film every enter the
train precisely in sixth minute
so that's that's what he has done
and when we showed it to our friends and
families and when we were
taking reactions from them uh there were
a lot of there were a lot of reactions
coming in but uh like what I was telling
earlier this is the first genre film
coming out of Extreme Action genre from
coming out of India so uh you know there
are
few people who understand this kind of a
genre so we were told lots of times they
were they were they were
um you know suggestions that we should
increase the Love Story We should we
should have the more love story so that
we will feel more for the uh for the boy
for the girl uh but we we actually stuck
on the fact that no it's a genre film we
need to
uh keep the genre its importance I can't
imagine what was it like actually
showing the film because again I don't
know how much genre films go to India
but what was it like showing it to
people who maybe not seen genre films
that much and watching something with as
much blood and action for the first time
oh so uh most of it uh when the people
who watched it they were shocked they
were shocked and they were pleasantly
shocked they were surprised and so you
know we were thinking that maybe the uh
maybe the girls would not like it
and it was it was a surprise there was
they were screaming they were shrieking
and they wanted to watch more and they
wanted to watch more blood and like one
of one of my uh one of my friends said
it's a it's a date film it's a date for
me I want to go uh go to uh watch this
film with my boyfriend because I want to
hold his hand and I I want him to
protect me while while watching this
this film so so you know this this is
it's a it's a very different reaction I
was expecting a completely different
reaction but when I uh showed the film
to her and uh two more friends of hers
they were oh my goodness they were they
were just ecstatic I would go with my
girlfriend to watch this film because
I'm really scared of these type of films
I'm scared I don't like like when I see
I but I want to go with my girlfriend
and me
you know those typical I remember this
very Vivid reaction that I got from a
friend of mine who saw the film uh
Shauna uh she said uh there were times
when I didn't want to watch the film but
it was so tempting and so um catchy that
I was watching it with one eye close and
one eye open it's a guilty pleasure for
her so that's the kind of reaction that
we got from the film that of course it's
a little uncomfortable to watch the
amount of blood that we have uh shred in
the film and it's all him you know this
man he loves blood to another level
there was a sequence I remember in the
film you if you remember or not the fire
extinguisher thing and the leftover of
that yeah I was gonna say but you want
to be specific but yes there is a fire
extinguisher in the movie that is used
to inflict things yeah so
I mean yeah it's all him and uh there
was this moment when he came on the sets
and he saw the blood he came like this
looking at you know the blood like that
and he touched the blood and he held it
like that he's like it doesn't seem
thick enough
make it make it thicker and I'm just
looking at him I said oh God
he's my director I mean there is uh you
know streak of violence in him I should
be very uh careful of him now yeah so
there is there is a reason to it
actually uh so there's a serious reason
to it and uh you know I feel blood is a
symbol of ambition greed and sacrifice
you know so in the film there is
somebody's ambition and greed and then
there is a sacrifice a lot of people are
getting sacrificed because of that
ambition and greed so so as you as you
near I as you uh go towards the end of
the film you will see that the blood has
increased the flow of blood has
increased
it's actually uh it's actually actually
very conscious decision to keep
increasing the blood till the end of the
film you guys are part of switching
subjects you guys are part of Tiff
Midnight Madness and uh I'm curious what
does it mean for all three of you to be
a part of this film festival and you
know premiering here in a section of the
of the festival that means a lot to a
lot of people which is midnight madness
oh it's it was overwhelming I I just
um like even right now the feeling is
still sinking in
um it's just a great honor to be here
this is the first time we've come here
uh this is the first time
um my film has has come to Toronto I
have come for the first time I'm in
Canada and uh when we started making the
film we had no idea that you know our
world premier is going to happen over
here
so at midnight madness which is which is
the place to be for a genre film so I'm
very very happy very excited and uh
couldn't have been better actually
couldn't have been better I'm really
overwhelmed that's as Sir said
such a prestigious
film festival
and such a wonderful segment Midnight
Madness
this is my first International Film
Festival as an actor and people are not
giving me time to for me to you know for
the feelings to sink in because
sometimes there's interviews and all
when I go back home
to India I'll sit I'll meditate I put a
candle on and I'll just keep thinking
about it that what happened with me I'm
really so uh
happy and proud of myself I think sir is
also proud of me oh yes of course yes so
yeah I I feel it's uh it's too good to
be true to be honest with you it's too
good to be true when the news uh when I
got the news from gunit like my my
producer she she broke the news to me
saying that you know the film has made
it to Tiff
I said Okay that was the only reaction I
had because I thought it's too good yeah
I mean it's impossible it's my debut
film it's my first film it's it's
massive and I just kept the phone down
and I told a friend of mine yeah
my film is going uh for Toronto Film
Festival he said what are you are you
serious you know how what that means I
said I know what it means but I think
probably I mean something will happen or
the other
everything uh came through yesterday
when I was watching the film
the way people reacted oh God it was
something that I've never felt in my
life I had somebody sitting on my left I
had somebody sitting on my right there
was a guy sitting right behind me
the reaction the way they reacted one
more time one more time go for it one
more time we want part two we want so
that reaction made it all so real for me
and all it was so overwhelming as he
said I just wanted 10 seconds to just
cry come back and just sit sure which I
never got so I think
I'm grateful I am immensely blessed I'm
immensely lucky to be to be here to be
sitting in front of you and you know
doing this interview I feel um I feel
it's a it's a feeling that I I probably
will never feel again I want to retain
it I want to feel it every minute of my
life now I feel is that being able to
believe that we are getting a standing
ovation after the film The when the film
ended and I
and most of them were foreigners they
were not indians they don't know us more
well but still they were standing for us
and clapping I was reading the film they
didn't know us nobody knew us yeah they
just loved the film I I what's funny is
I watched the film The Day Before the
premiere and I as I was watching it and
as it ended I said oh my God I wish I
could be in the theater to watch this
with the Midnight Madness crowd because
I could have told you that was gonna
happen but it was just it's past my
bedtime I couldn't do it it was crazy
right it was you know what I mean it
would have opened you up from the street
so I really want uh there's there needs
to be a special mention uh for the
producers can Dharma uh like I was
saying that this is the first of its
kind coming from India and the kind of
conviction
and support which they have provided uh
to the film it's immense I'm I'm like
truly grateful to them that you know
when there's a these are not tested
Waters
this is a this is a first of its kind
sure and like your first question when
you said that was it difficult
it was not difficult it was they they
were uh they're fully sold on the fact
that we need to come out with this it's
high time
and um I'm really really grateful to uh
to Karan to apurva uh that they actually
made this happen really yeah they
trusted it so to put in this kind of
belief
uh in a film like this when there is no
president
it's it's it's just uh immense I don't
want to be specific with what happens in
the movie who lives who dies all that
stuff but
I am curious if the reaction from this
plus your experience making the movie do
you have an appetite for making another
genre film yes
I've tasted the blood pretty exactly
and it tastes like candy yeah well it
tastes sweet
the blood we used was sweet right but
being serious is it one of these things
where you are already in your mind
thinking about what am I going to do
next and are the producers so happy that
they're like what can we do now yes so
we are already thinking about uh a
sequel so if you want to make it a
franchise of uh franchise films
so very soon we will be working we go
next year too yeah part two part two
yeah but you honestly don't like I mean
everyone involved who may who financed
the movie has to be incredibly happy
they're like they know what they have
yes you know yes I'm happy yesterday I
hope I am curious though do genre films
typically play well in India or is it
just a question of like like the raid
did that do well like so John Wick four
sure uh it was playing for four weeks
and was going houseful
so you know uh the one two three and
four all four have done phenomenally
well in India
which is uh which itself means that
genre films are working
uh I don't think raid had raid released
in India uh it was although this is just
like a mention of a genre yeah I just
mean like I just don't know
was running for three weeks yeah when it
was not so it was not promoted so much
in India still it was running for three
weeks
which is just by Word of Mouth
people like to watch all of this you
know everybody
so I feel it's accessible to everybody
now Ott Netflix Amazon so people are
watching everything if you make a good
film and you put it out there I mean
people are gonna watch it anyway I I
have a theory uh to that you know during
kovid a lot of people were at home
and they got exposed to like a person
who's sitting in the the remotest of
town must have seen uh films coming from
Korea and Germany and France and Japan
now the very ex the very much exposed to
International Cinema it's a good point
yeah so uh you know so the films which
were made before covet and when they
were released after covet they didn't do
that well because the audience had moved
moved on so yeah yes because they're
more they're much more aware now and
they're more adaptive there are the
audience is very intelligent yes they're
not fools yes I totally agree uh and
like look at RR in America and how well
that did but yes listen I I have to end
with you even though I could ask you a
thousand other questions because I have
another interview and I'm sure you have
other things you'd rather do than talk
to me so I will just say a sincere
congratulations I'm really happy for you
guys I know people are gonna love it
thank you for coming in thank you so
much thank you for having us thank you